[Music]
The Walking Dead Season 9 has just
dropped it's midseason finale and whilst
the show won't be back until 2019 that
doesn't mean that there isn't a lot to
unpack throughout this video I'll be
breaking down the teaser trailer for
episode 9 as well as giving my
predictions for what could happen down
the line there are huge spoilers here
for episode 8 so if you aren't fully
caught up then I suggest that you turn
off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to episode 9 of The Walking Dead is
fittingly called new enemy and I think
it's a pretty safe bet to assume that we
will be focusing heavily on the
introduction of the whisperers in the
teaser trailer we see that the group
managed to make it back from the
cemetery in which Jesus was killed we
then get a clip of the funeral for the
character I've seen a couple people say
that Jesus is not dead and that you can
in fact see him breathing
however this confirms his departure the
actor the place the character has also
confirmed that he will no longer be in
the show so it seems likely to be true
in a voiceover we are told that there's
a new enemy and we get a couple of shots
of bida
Peter is a high-ranking member of the
whisperers that eventually becomes the
group's leader after the demise of alpha
beta is completely wrapped up in his
persona as a whisperer and refuses to
remove the mask he wears over his face
he is massively protective over it and
kills allies and enemies without
question when they ask him to take it
off he's about seven foot tall and is a
massively dominant character I loved
seeing him in this teaser and he
actually has an extremely interesting
backstory before the apocalypse a beer
was a famous basketball player and actor
and he starred in several movies and car
commercials
to me he's become completely enveloped
in this new role as a zombie apocalypse
survivor and I can't wait to see what
the show does with him the trailer also
hints that the group of infiltrated the
whisperers hideout but I doubt that
taking it down will be easy it also
appears that they might be showcasing
that some characters may switch sides
and there's a tease that daryl may in
fact have more on
with the whisperers than he does his old
friends another huge hint in the teaser
trailer of what could happen is the fall
of the kingdom Carroll says to Ezekiel
this could be your last chance and in an
exchange with Michonne Sadiq asks what
does it mean for Alexandria to survive
if Kingdom falls to me the show is
definitely setting up the fall of
Kingdom and I personally think that
writing out the location makes a lot of
sense currently in the show there are so
many different strongholds that it's
becoming difficult to give all of them
that required time they need to fully
develop so it makes a lot of sense for
me to write out the kingdom the trailer
closes with a shot of alpha in a puddle
which confirms that the whisperers are
here to stay alpha is even worse than
beta and since the apocalypse has done
many brutal things in the comic book she
physically and emotionally abused her
own daughter and allowed several people
to rape her in the comics negan is the
one who kills her and beautifully
beheads her and I can't wait to see if
this is carried over to the show in
season 9 so what are your thoughts on
what will happen when season 9 returns
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the mid-season finale which will be
linked at the end of this video this is
a channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you